Trascrizione: Ale Unam
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera.
Allora, quanti hanno l'auricolare
collegato con la partita dell'Italia?
Qualcuno c'è - o con l'App
per le notifiche.
Perché un po’ mi sento
in quel pezzo di film
della "Corazzata Potemkin" di Fantozzi,
però dalla parte sbagliata.
Allora i film, come quello di Fantozzi,
così come il teatro, così come i fumetti,
sono tutte delle finizioni;
però sono linguaggi
che forse, delle volte,
ci raccontano delle verità
meglio di tante parole.
E stasera parliamo di supereroi.
Partiamo col primo supereroe:
ho scelto Superman,
supereroe per antonomasia.
Superman è un po particolare,
perché è un supereroe contrario.
Tutti i supereroi, nei fumetti,
sono degli umani
che si travestono da supereroi;
mentre Superman è un supereroe
che si traveste da umano
perché viene da un altro
pianeta, da Krypton;
e il costume, il mantello,
è fatto con la coperta
con cui è venuto sul pianeta Terra.
E Superman mi ispira il tema del talento.
E la prima considerazione che faccio
è che Superman, su Krypton,
è un normodotato,
è normale come tutti gli altri;
sulla Terra, invece,
ha dei superpoteri straordinari.
Allora il talento
è una questione di contesto:
cioè ciascuno di noi ha del talento,
ha delle abilità che gli vengono
un po' meglio degli altri;
ma deve trovare, deve avere il coraggio
di trovare il contesto
dove può esprimere questo potenziale;
e se noi siamo dei leader,
secondo me è un dovere trovare i contesti
dove i nostri follower e collaboratori
possono dare il meglio.
È finita l'epoca di vedere, secondo me,
ad esempio le organizzazioni
come delle fotografie,
dove tu hai la casellina
e metti dentro la persona.
No, le organizzazioni sono come dei film:
quindi devi lavorare nel tempo,
e allora puoi fare convergere
quelle che sono le tue organizzazioni
con il talento dei tuoi collaboratori
e delle persone che ti seguono
e, piano piano, far convergere
talento e posizione che occuperanno,
così le persone svilupperanno
il loro potenziale
e tu avrai un'organizzazione
super performante.
E poi, un'altra cosa che Superman
mi insegna sul talento
è che la cosa particolare
che un po' accomuna tutti i supereroi
è che quando acquisiscono i superpoteri
devono imparare a usarli;
quando noi abbiamo un talento, secondo me,
è nostro dovere, soprattutto all'inizio,
investire tempo ed energie
per svilupparlo.
Non dobbiamo accontentarci che qualcosa
ci venga meglio degli altri;
dobbiamo trasformarlo in eccellenze.
E per fare questo dobbiamo continuare
a imparare, studiare
e dall'altra parte allenarci,
mettere in pratica, anche sbagliando,
per potenziare appunto il nostro talento.
Però arriverà un certo punto
in cui i miglioramenti
diventeranno sempre più difficili
e le energie per migliorare
sempre più grandi.
E tra l'altro poi a un certo punto,
quando si avvicina l'eccellenza,
i miglioramenti li colgono
soltanto pochissime persone: gli esperti.
Se noi guardiamo
uno sport che non conosciamo
non riusciamo a capire
la grandezza del gesto tecnico.
Una volta, una notte insonne,
apro la televisione e vedo il curling,
non so se avete presente
lo sport invernale,
vedevo queste bocce sul ghiaccio,
le persone con la scopetta
e mi veniva da dire:
con questa roba qua,
posso andare anch’io alle Olimpiadi!
Perché non conoscendo quello sport,
non riesco ad apprezzare il gesto tecnico.
Quando noi cresciamo,
abbiamo investito nella prima parte
della nostra vita sul talento,
lì dobbiamo avere la forza e il coraggio
di investire il nostro non talento:
cioè di investire in quelle attività
che proprio non ci vengono.
Perché?
Perché lì, visto che partiamo
molto dal basso,
con poco possiamo raggiungere
dei buoni risultati;
non diventeremo dei fenomeni,
ma dei buoni risultati.
La nostra performance complessiva
migliorerà di tantissimo.
Questo è Superman.
Poi, un altro supereroe interessante,
intrigante: Wonder Woman.
È la prima supereroina della DC Comics,
è del 1941.
E quando nasce questa supereroina,
perché sono nati prima supereroi maschi,
come sempre a quell'epoca,
non parte benissimo
perché è una donna guerriera,
per cui parte con attributi maschili.
E c'è stato tutto un periodo
in cui una donna per esprimersi
doveva in qualche modo copiare gli uomini.
E il peggior complimento
che si poteva fare
è "quella donna ha le p…",
darle delle caratteristiche
di genere maschile:
come sei brava perché sei come un maschio.
Invece Wonder Woman si evolve,
man mano nell'epoca fino ai film di oggi,
e rappresenta sempre, un po',
come si è sviluppata
la leadership al femminile;
è molto interessante,
perché nei primi anni '70
diventa un'icona femminista
e oggi, nell'evoluzione che sta compiendo,
abbiamo una supereroina indipendente,
che non ha paura di stare da sola
perché è legata al passato
ma non fa della tradizione
un modello assoluto.
Cioè per dire: allora,
per essere realizzata devi sposarti,
avere un figlio maschio
e una figlia femmina.
Lei riconosce queste tradizioni,
ma non diventano un vincolo
per l'autorealizzazione.
E poi ha l'intelligenza emotiva:
non nasconde le proprie emozioni,
non ha paura di mostrarle.
Allora io quello che penso,
studiando la leadership,
è che forse oggi è arrivato il tempo
in cui sono i maschi a dover imparare
la leadership dalle donne;
perché oggi, per essere un ottimo leader
devi avere la capacità
di relazionarti bene
con ciascuna dei tuoi collaboratori;
per cui devi, in qualche modo, avere
la capacità di ascolto attivo, di empatia,
la capacità di entrare
nei panni dei tuoi collaboratori,
devi avere l'intelligenza emotiva.
Per cui oggi si sono ribaltate,
secondo me, le situazioni:
sono i maschi,
che devono imparare dalle donne
per come essere leader.
E poi un supereroe
che mi piace tantissimo,
proprio che piace a tutti, è Wolverine.
Wolverine è pazzesco perché ha
lo scheletro di adamantio,
ha la capacità di rigenerarsi,
gli spuntano le lame dalle mani.
A me fa un po' sorridere,
perché la traduzione italiana
dell'animale Wolverine, è il ghiottone.
Uno dice: cattivi state attenti,
arriva il ghiottone!
E a me fa ridere perché non ha
quella forza, diciamo quell'impatto:
Wolverine, il ghiottone.
Però il superpotere che ha
è quello che è immortale,
che è un superpotere che noi umani
invidiamo tantissimo a Wolverine,
perché da sempre abbiamo cercato
di diventare immortali.
Anche gli egizi, con le Piramidi
e la mummificazione,
anche sempre la ricerca
della vita oltre la vita.
Poi le tecniche, le tecnologie,
le cryocose e non ci siamo mai riusciti.
E anche qua c'è un po’
una differenza di genere,
le donne sono avvantaggiate
perché sono già un po immortali,
avendo il dono della procreazione,
per cui proseguono la specie.
Noi a quel dono diamo
un contributo piccolino -
talvolta anche troppo
rapido, qualcuno dice.
E noi maschi invece vogliamo
in qualche modo rimanere,
e lasciare una traccia,
per cui scrivere un libro,
avere una strada intitolata,
un modo per rimanere immortali;
perché effettivamente, se ci pensiamo,
quand'è che uno rimane immortale?
Quando viene ricordato.
Il regalo più grande
che possiamo fare alle persone care
è quello di ricordarle,
di averne un pezzettino nel nostro cuore,
in modo che così rimangano
veramente immortali.
Allora Wolverine è immortale,
ha questo superpotere immenso,
eppure è infelice.
Ma come?
Tutti vogliamo essere lui,
e lui ce l'ha ed è infelice.
Perché?
Per due motivi: il primo è perché
tutte le persone che conosce,
invece, sono mortali,
per cui lui, appena
si affeziona ad una persona,
sa già che la dovrà perdere,
e questa è una tragedia che non sopporta
e che lo porterà poi, di fatto,
a non volersi più affezionare a nessuno.
Il secondo motivo è perché ha
tutto il tempo del mondo a disposizione.
Allora se hai tutto il tempo
del mondo a disposizione,
nulla diventa importante,
perché puoi fare tutto quando vorrai.
E questo, secondo me,
è un insegnamento molto grande per noi
perché noi che siamo mortali,
siamo fortunatamente mortali,
abbiamo una scadenza,
anche se fortunatamente
non sappiamo quando sarà,
e ci permette, questo tempo limitato,
di farci concentrare
sulle cose veramente importanti,
di non cadere nella trappola
di questa modernità.
Ci fosse Calindri direbbe:
il logorio della vita moderna.
Noi siamo molto reattivi:
arriva una telefonata,
dobbiamo risolvere quella telefonata;
una mail - quella mail;
un Whatsapp, dobbiamo rispondere.
Siamo molto, molto reattivi.
Però, l'essere troppo reattivi
ci fa perdere forse di vista
cosa sono veramente le cose importanti.
L'esempio è sempre quello che:
ti manda un Whatsapp e ti scrive:
ti ho mandato una mail.
E ti senti in obbligo di vedere:
sa che l'ho letto!
Vai a vedere la mail, e c'è scritto:
chiamami e devi chiamarlo.
Ma perché?
Perché non posso più gestire il mio tempo?
Ecco se cadiamo nella trappola,
in questa trincea,
facciamo come i criceti:
corriamo, ma alla fine stiamo fermi.
Invece, ricordarci
che non possiamo gestire il tempo
perché il tempo passa, possiamo
soltanto impiegarlo bene o male.
E Wolverine mi ricorda, tutte le volte,
che tu devi impiegarlo bene,
per le cose importanti.
E poi ci sono i Fantastici Quattro.
I Fantastici Quattro
sono il primo gruppo della Marvel.
Sono del 1961.
Fino ad allora, gli eroi erano solitari,
erano dei supereroi solo solitari.
E poi la DC Comics,
concorrente della Marvel,
fa la Justice League,
mette insieme dei supereroi.
I fumetti vendono tantissimo,
e la Marvel dice:
dobbiamo fare i nostri supereroi.
Chiamano Stan Lee,
che è il più grande creatore
di supereroi che abbiamo avuto,
e Stan Lee decide di fare
i Fantastici Quattro,
e lui dice:
io voglio farli di carne e sangue,
voglio farli che sono molto umani
perché questi supereroi erano
un po’ lontani dall'umano
e i Fantastici Quattro -
Qual è il trucco che usa?
Li fa legare.
Per cui c'è Mister Fantastic,
quello che si può allungare,
che è sposato con la Donna Invisibile.
Apro una parentesi:
anche lì, Donna invisibile
perché è una caratteristica
un po’ delle donne, l'invisibilità;
lì diventa un super potere.
E poi la Donna invisibile
è sorella della Torcia Umana,
di quello che si infiamma.
E poi c'è Ben Grimm, la Cosa,
quello fatto di pietra,
e l'uomo allungabile,
Mister Fantastic, sono migliori amici.
Quindi, questi legami affettivi
portano un sacco di discussioni;
però portano anche, di fatto,
una solidarietà enorme
perché è veramente un po’
tutti per uno  e uno per tutti,
perché si vogliono bene.
Quindi c'è un legame affettivo,
e dall'altra parte c'è
una diversità assoluta.
Sono molto diversi,
e questa diversità li porta
a un sacco di litigi.
Perché?
Perché gestire la diversità
è faticosissimo;
ma dall'altra parte
è una ricchezza enorme, enorme;
perché se io ho persone uguali a me,
al limite posso potenziare
le mie capacità, posso fare di più;
ma se ho persone diverse da me
possiamo fare tante cose
che mai ci immaginavamo insieme.
E studiando i Fantastici Quattro,
mi è venuto in mente un episodio
che mi è capitato qualche anno fa,
quando si viaggiava.
Ero negli Stati Uniti,
vado a visitare il Grand Canyon,
e un fenomeno rarissimo: la nebbia.
Non si vedeva niente.
Mi era capitato anche da ragazzo:
ero andato a Capo Nord,
qualcuno non viene in vacanza
con me per la nebbia;
ma questa è un'altra storia.
Insomma, non si vede niente
e andiamo tutti nel negozio di souvenir;
lì ci sono i navajo,
gli indiani, i nativi.
Andiamo lì, guardiamo le cose.
Il negozio è pieno.
Entra un signore arrabbiatissimo,
così arrabbiato che parla ad alta voce,
dice: com'è possibile?
È tutta la vita che sogno
di vedere il Grand Canyon,
ho fatto un viaggio lunghissimo,
sono qua da sei ore
e non lo sto vedendo.
Noi ci allontaniamo un po’,
perché è un po’ agitato;
e a un certo punto,
incrocia con lo sguardo la commessa.
La guarda e gli dice:
ehi, tu cosa hai da guardare?
Lei non aveva fatto niente,
però in qualche modo
doveva scaricare questa rabbia;
e questa commessa,
invece di abbassare lo sguardo
come avrei fatto io,
che non sono un Cuor di Leone,
sostiene lo sguardo di questo signore.
E gli dice: guarda, posso capire
che ogni tanto sul Grand Canyon
ci sia la nebbia;
ma quello che non riesco a capire
è come si fanno a dedicare solo sei ore
al sogno della propria vita.
Questo signore si calma, esce,
non so se si è buttato
dal Canyon, non l'ho seguito.
Però questa roba qua
mi ha illuminato, perché?
Perché una persona diversissima da te,
forse proprio perché
non c'entra niente con te,
ti può aprire uno spiraglio
che per te diventa un panorama
completamente nuovo.
Lì ho capito la forza e la diversità,
e anche la difficoltà,
di accettare il punto di vista diverso.
Ecco: questo è quello che mi ha insegnato
i Fantastici Quattro.
E poi arrivo all'ultimo supereroe
che è Spider-Man, l'Uomo Ragno.
L'Uomo Ragno è favoloso:
è il primo supereroe adolescente,
quindi che va a scuola,
tanto che è un po’ scanzonato.
A me diverte molto,
perché prende in giro i nemici
mentre li combatte.
E sdrammatizzare, delle volte,
è un'ottima terapia
per affrontare le cose impegnative.
Spider-Man però non diventa supereroe
quando acquisisce i poteri,
quando lo punge il ragno radioattivo.
Ha soltanto dei superpoteri,
non è ancora un supereroe.
Diventa supereroe
quando uno dei due filosofi
più importanti nel mondo fantasy -
uno è lo Zio Sam dell'Uomo Ragno,
e l'altro Yoda di Guerre Stellari  -
lo Zio Sam gli dice: "grandi poteri
comportano grandi responsabilità".
In quel momento lì, lui diventa supereroe.
Non è questione di avere potere, o poteri,
è una questione del perché li uso,
è il senso che do.
Infatti, se ci pensiamo,
anche i cattivi, gli antieroi,
hanno un sacco di poteri, di superpoteri.
Non sono differenti
da quel punto di vista;
solo che l'antieroe cambia il perché.
L'antieroe lo fa in maniera egoistica,
usa i propri poteri per dominare,
per sconfiggere, per fare male,
per distruggere il pianeta;
mentre il supereroe
lo fa per aiutare gli altri,
e per salvare il pianeta.
Quindi quello che conta
è il perché, più che il cosa.
E anche questo mi è venuto in mente
mentre suonavano i ragazzi prima,
bravissimi, che suonavano Battiato,
che settimana scorsa, martedì,
vado in un negozio di strumenti musicali.
Entro e vedo un signore, un commesso,
che avrà avuto più della mia età,
non lo dico però insomma,
molti chilometri sulle spalle,
quindi avrà venduto centinaia
di migliaia di chitarre
e stava vendendo una chitarra
ad un ragazzino, un piccolo ragazzo.
E quello che mi ha colpito è che,
nonostante fosse un lavoro
che facesse da 20 anni,
sempre lo stesso lavoro,
sempre gli stessi strumenti eccetera
oh, come toccava quello strumento,
la passione che ci metteva
nel descriverlo,
l'entusiasmo, quel luccichio
che vedevo negli occhi,
mi ha fatto capire che quel signore
non stava vedendo una chitarra
ma stava aiutando quel ragazzo
a realizzare il sogno
di diventare un musicista.
Allora ricordarci ogni tanto
il perché facciamo le cose
forse è la lezione più importante
che mi hanno dato i supereroi.
E forse, tutte le volte
che noi facciamo un gesto così,
con un perché importante,
stiamo in qualche modo esercitando
i nostri superpoteri
probabilmente senza saperli di avere.
Grazie.